okay cool I think that we can officially
get started so hello all you lovely
people is so nice to see you all here
I'm really pleased that you've chosen to
come over to this session and so to
introduce myself I am Steve and I work
at Microsoft I work on the asp net team
and i spend all my time working on this
thing blazer and fun fact for you all
blazer
started here at NDC Oslo it was
originally just a little demo in a
conference presentation here two years
ago and the people said we like that so
much you've got to do it you've got to
make that a real thing and turn that
into an actual product so we had no
choice at all we had to just go and do
this thing but you're all responsible so
in a way I think we can say we are all
the mummies and daddies of Blaser we are
you know is in all how of our hearts I
think that I think you'd agree right or
possibly you've never even heard of this
thing at all and if that's the case I'd
I need to get a sense of that so can you
give me a show of hands if you've got
any sense of what blazar is you've heard
anything about like every single person
cool good all right so um when I do this
talk I'm gonna give you some I'll do a
little bit of introductory stuff because
there may be some people who either
haven't really seen it or they can't
really remember it but I know a lot of
you will know the basics so I'll go
through the basics pretty quick and then
we'll start getting onto some slightly
more advanced and newer stuff so what is
this thing anyway
well good chance you know but just in
case you don't and the basic situation
with web development these days is that
you've got some code that runs on a web
server maybe it's in the cloud somewhere
which is your application logic but it's
not all of your application logic
because you also need to make a user
interface appear to your users and they
are in a web browser so how do you make
a UI appear in a web browser well the
traditional answer has been you use one
of these things a JavaScript framework
and you go about your day-to-day
development life and you're happy and
you make your UI so that's all very well
but it's a bit limiting really isn't it
if the only way you can do a UI is using
a JavaScript technology or something
that compiles to JavaScript and that got
us thinking on the.net team
wouldn't it be cool if we could use some
of the new emerging technologies like
webassembly
or well it was emerging two years ago
it's pretty well-established now to
enable you to write your front-end web
application with net inside the browser
and that is the the original idea of
blazer it was to build on the ability to
run dotnet on web assembly and enable
you to build a rich user interface that
runs in a purely standards-compliant way
no plugins inside your browser and
hopefully make you very productive okay
so let's just have a look at the basics
of a blazer web application which I know
a lot of you may have seen before so
we'll go through it pretty quick so when
you create a new project whether you use
Visual Studio in Windows or whether you
use the command line tool on Linux or
Mac or on Windows then when you first
create it it looks like this so it's a
pretty typical dashboard a kind of
website which has got a couple of
different pages in it that we can do
client-side navigation and we can click
a button to increment a counter and
behind all that is dotnet code so if we
look over here in Visual Studio and we
zoom in a bit we can have a look and
we'll see that we've got no Java Script
in our application
we've got c-sharp files and razor files
so what's a raise a file well it's the
new name for CS HTML when you're using
get inside blazer and each one of those
razor files is a component players who
is a component based UI framework so you
build your application out of lots of
components for example the counter
component this is what we had just here
when I was clicking this button and if
we look we can see it uses a page
directive to say that this is the
component we should display when the
user is on this URL we have got some
HTML markup and we've got some c-sharp
code because we're able to run your
c-sharp in the browser now so we've
defined this current count we're
displaying the current count and we've
got a button that says when you click it
we're gonna call a c-sharp method and it
will increment the count and similarly
if we switch over onto this fetch data
page you'll see again we've got a page
directive to say that it's what we
display when we're on this URL we are
able to inject services from the
dependency injection system and here
we're injecting and
to be client so we can make a request to
the server and if we scroll way way way
down here we can see that when this
component is first initialized it's
going to make an HTTP request for some
JSON data which comes back
asynchronously and we're going to
deserialize it as an array of weather
forecast objects and then once we've got
that we can do this simple c-sharp loop
over those forecasts and produce the
HTML necessary for that bit of UI okay
so pretty straightforward stuff are we
going to get on to building bigger and
more interesting application in a few
minutes but before we get there let's do
a little bit of a warm-up and remind
ourselves what the basic programming
model in Blaser is so let's make this
page here this fetch date page a little
bit more interactive let's say we look
at the weather and we think I don't
really like that weather
I want to change it something else so
let's make the way there editable shall
we let's say I want to be able to edit
the temperature well how can I do that
well I can do so basically using normal
HTML so I can say instead of displaying
the template you see I'm going to have
an input type equals number because it
is a number and then I'm going to tell
Blazer to bind the value of that to the
temperature in C so we can now edit it
and we can do a couple more things too
so let's say instead of the temperature
in Fahrenheit being fixed to whatever
the server said we are going to compute
it dynamically so we're going to say
it's the temperature C times 2 plus 30
because I hear that is approximately the
formula for doing that and then finally
let's display something else let's
display some overall statistics about
the weather for the entire week so if
you had to describe the weather
throughout an entire week what sort of
statistic would you use well like
everybody any normal person in the
street they say what's the total
temperature going to be this week how
many degrees will be happening
altogether so we'll say total
temperature this this I have to type it
week is going to be will get the
forecasts and we are going to sum over
all of the forecasts temperature C
values okay and then
we can say it's that many degrees in
total this week but one more thing we
have to do before the forecast data has
been loaded it's going to be null so I'm
going to use the question mark operator
to say when we don't have that data
we're just going to have null there
instead okay
so let's see if now we've got an
editable weather page it looks like we
have so I can click on these up and down
buttons and you'll see the temperature
in F will go up as I do that so does the
total temperature and if we make it
really warm tomorrow you'll see like the
total temperature properly reacts to
that okay so there is some basic Blazer
programming concepts we've got page
directives we can inject services we can
display HTML we can include c-sharp
expressions in our HTML we can do
c-sharp control flow with loops we can
use bind to birth display and read data
from the user we can put arbitrary
c-sharp code in we can make requests to
the server and we can work with custom
types all that sort of typical blazer
programming experience alright so
there's your basics of blazer I hope
you're ready now to move on to something
a little bit more interesting and
advanced and first I want to get into
how this stuff is actually working
behind the scenes so I've been telling
you that we can run your dotnet code in
the browser but how exactly does that
work I've been saying the word web
assembly quite a lot but what what even
is that and what does it look like on
the inside
so to make your code running the browser
there we're using a stack of three
technologies and the bottom layer in our
cake here is web assembly so web
assembly is a bytecode format for the
web which has been supported in all the
browsers for two years now so that's all
the desktop browsers and all the mobile
browsers they all support it it's not a
new or experimental thing this is it's
just been there for a long time by now
and the idea with web assembly is that
you can take your code from whatever
language you want to work in and compile
it to web assembly and it's the bytecode
format that is designed for performance
and simplicity really so it's going to
run the same in all the browsers and it
should be able to get to within about a
factor of two of running at natives
that's webassembly itself okay now in
terms of how we run your dotnet code a
reasonable person might guess at this
stage that we've found some way of
compiling dotnet to webassembly
that's be a completely reasonable guess
but it's actually not true
that's not what we're doing at this
stage although it is something that we
are working on doing at some point well
some point fairly soon but currently
what we're doing to run your code is
we've taken a dotnet runtime and we've
compiled that to webassembly instead so
we can load this dotnet runtime into the
browser and then that can load and
execute normal net assemblies and the
particular runtime that we're using here
is mono and if you're wondering why mono
well the answer is that Microsoft
currently produces ships and supports
three net runtimes we've got dotnet
corked on a framework and mono and of
those three mono is the one that's
designed most around portability so it
was the one that was by far the most
practical for us to compile and get
running on web assembly but in the long
run this doesn't even matter because as
you'll have seen with the.net 5
announcements this is all converging
anyway but for a long time for now
you're going to see the word mono
showing up maybe you'll always see the
word mono I don't know what the final
branding is going to be but it's not
really going to matter very much in the
long run anyway the final layer in our
technology cake is blazer itself and
that is the UI programming model so
that's the thing that knows about what
components are the the fact that
components have parameters they need to
get re-rendered they can be nested all
that kind of stuff that you've been
seeing already so let me actually prove
to you that some of the claims I've just
been making are actually true by showing
you this actually happening inside the
browser so we've got our blazer basics
thing here and if I pop open the browser
network tab and then I do a reload then
I'll zoom in a little bit and what we'll
see is this is all the stuff that we
sent down to the browser them so we've
sent the initial HTML page here which
contains a reference to this library
this tiny bit of Java it's not tiny
actually this bit of JavaScript called
blizzard web assembly Jas and that's the
thing that knows how to load and start
up the mono web assembly runtime so it
loads a few more things and then you'll
see it's loading mono wasum
and that is mono itself which has been
compiled to webassembly
and then into that we can load regular
dotnet dll's so we've loaded the normal
assembly for your application which has
been built by the normal c-sharp
compiler no weird magic involved and
then we also learned the various other
dependencies that we've got to make your
application actually load now if you're
wondering how big this thing actually is
let's try and measure that so I'm going
to disable my cache so I'm pretending to
be a completely fresh new user who's
never seen this before and will see that
the total amount of network traffic
involved in loading this thing is 2.3
megabytes
by default so that is on one hand that's
great because that's really small for
dotnet runtime normally darknet runtimes
are like hundreds of megabytes so we've
done a lot of work to bring it down to
two point three Meg's but at the same
time it's also a pretty large for a web
page so whether or not this is suitable
for your use cases depends on what they
are for some sort of internal business
application that's probably completely
fine for public facing applications
you've got more of a decision to make we
are working on bringing that down
further as time goes on but that's what
we've got to now and the other thing to
bear in mind is that this is only a
first-time thing of course it's cached
so if I enable caching and do this again
you'll see that the total amount of
network traffic transferred now 15.5
kilobytes so you know it really is just
a first-time think okay so what else can
we say about this
what is this mono dot Wasson thing what
is on the inside of that file
it's webassembly by code but what does
that actually look like can we see it
can we debug it the answer is yes we can
see it and we can debug it but it is not
a very useful thing to do but I'm just
gonna do it anyway so let's just close
these things because that's distracting
and we'll see that if we want to see the
inside of mono we can look in our
sources tab in this wasum folder here
webassembly and you'll see that it
contains hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of these tiny little snippets
of webassembly bytecode now these aren't
all separately fetched in different HTTP
requests that would be insane this is
just the browser giving you a sort of
human readable view of the inside of
manoda awesome
and so it converts all the binary
bytecode into this text-based format and
we can see all the different functions
that have been compiled there and if you
look at closely at it you'll see that
this bytecode format for web assembly is
a it's a stack based virtual machine
it's all about putting stuff on to a
stack making performing operations to
mutate the stuff that's on the stack and
you know getting it back off and it only
operates on basic numeric types and it's
designed all around performance but it's
not very interesting or useful to be
looking at your application at a
bytecode level if you really wanted to
debug your app you would want to see
your c-sharp source code right so how
can we do that because there is no
awareness of c-sharp in the web browser
well what we've done is we've created a
little debug server that runs in the
background when you're in development
mode and your browser can connect to
that and it tells the browser what's
going on inside monos runtime and if you
want to access it you'll see we've got
this debugging hotkey shift alt D or
shift command D if you're on a Mac so if
I press shift alt D right now you'll see
it pops up another set of the browser
dev tools and these are the real browser
dev tools they are connected to our
application so to prove that if I go to
the elements tab here and move this out
here then when I start hovering over
stuff you'll see that stuff gets
highlighted because it really is the
browser's actual dev tools there and if
we go on to the sources tab I can now
expand file and you'll start to see our
actual application source code so if
you've seen this before I can tell you
have got a few improvements that we've
added to that recently but one of them
is that we now show your application in
its original hierarchical folder
structure and not just one giant list of
files as we did until a few weeks ago so
that's cool another thing I'll show you
in a second but first observe that yes
we can see our c-sharp source code here
not just c-sharp we can also see our
RAZR code and if i want to set a
breakpoint then that's absolutely gonna
work so if I come back over here and
then I navigate to the fetch data page
you'll see we've hit that break point so
we're able to actually have a debugger
for
sooo shop code running inside the
browser tools and another thing that we
can do now that we couldn't do until a
few weeks ago is we can put some put a
breakpoint right in the middle of the
rendering logic as well if we want to so
if I go away from there and come back
you'll see we hit this breakpoint during
the rendering logic and better still if
you look down here you'll see we can now
start to inspect the shape of some of
the dotnet objects that are alive inside
that runtime so we've got this F
variable here which is of type weather
forecast and if we expand that you'll
see we can even see the properties on it
now this is not a complete production
ready debugging system there's a lot of
work left for us to do to make this
really ready as evidenced by the fact
that although we can display strings and
numbers we don't even have a way to
display date times just yet but we are
working on it we're going to add you
know all the low-level primitives of
dotnet will become available so that
you'll be able to properly debug your
application inside the browser there
okay right so that's some that's enough
about what's going on behind the scenes
there we've looked to how mono dot wasum
gets loaded and what's inside that and
we've seen a little bit about debugging
but now I want to build something bigger
or more interesting and using this other
application I'm going to be able to show
you some of the newer things that we've
just shipped in the last month or two so
I'm gonna switch projects now I'm gonna
switch over to this other thing which I
call Mission Control
so what's Mission Control well as I've
told you my day job is being a developer
on the SP nut core team and working on
blazer
but I have this little side project that
I do in the evenings and weekends which
is running a network of spies and secret
agents who mostly operates around New
York City and so I've created this
application here that lets me track
where all my agents are and on what
their current missions are ok so let's
run it and then we'll talk about how it
works so when it comes up you'll see it
looks kind of familiar because it's the
same basic structure as the thing I
showed you before it's got a side bar
which is sort of slidy in this case and
I can switch from home on to agents and
it's going to get a list of my agents
from my back-end data source there and
display and
I've deliberately made it look quite
similar to the default project template
so that it's easier for you to
understand the structure but we are
going to add some more interesting
things to it okay so let's just see how
does this agents page just to remind
ourselves what that sort of code looks
like well firstly let's have a look at
the overall solution structure you'll
see this time instead of having just one
project I've now got three and this is
what you get when you use the Blazer
hosted on asp net core project template
it gives you three projects a client
project which is your client side blazer
application that runs under web assembly
inside the browser it also gives you a
server project which is a regular
server-side asp net core application and
that's got two jobs really the first job
is to actually serve the client
application to the browser and the
second job is to be a place where you
can put your server-side API endpoints
so that you can deal with things like
interacting with a database enforcing
security rules or that kind of thing and
then finally we've got the last and best
project which is the shared project and
it's best because it can be used in both
places it's simply a regular net
standard class library that's referenced
by both client and server which means if
you ever need to exchange data between
the two server and client worlds as you
always do then you can guarantee that
they've both got the same representation
of the data
you're never gonna have a situation
where they're out of sync and one thinks
that the data has different properties
than the other and we'll look at that a
little bit more in a minute but next
let's see how that agents page was
implemented so it will be very familiar
to you just like the weather data page
it's got a page directive it injects the
HTTP client and then down at the bottom
we do an HTTP request to get the list of
agents we don't have to define the
agents class here because that's in the
shared project so that the server knows
how to send that data as well okay now
what about the styling of this thing you
may notice if you're a keen observer of
UX that this is following the Google
material design sort of styling and the
way I've done that is I've used a
component library one of the key design
goals of Blazer
is that should be really easy for you to
take a library of components to do
common things like grids and tabs and
all that kind of thing and just use it
in your application and those libraries
should be able to bring styling to you
as well and we also need to make it easy
to create those libraries and we'll get
onto that in a minute but right now
we're using one of those libraries and
let me show you how we can use it a
little bit more so I want to use my
material design component library to
improve this loading experience
currently it just says the word loading
but if I wanted to make it a little bit
cooler I could delete that loading thing
there and I'm going to use a material
design linear progress bar and since I
won't say what the progress proportion
is it's just going to display a sort of
indefinite spinner so when I reload now
you'll see we get this cool little
spinny effect going on as we appear
there so that's just to show you that we
can use a component from a library and
we'll look more about how to create
those libraries in a bit now that's how
the application is hosted on a SP nut
core on the server what about something
a bit different authentication and
authorization well that's quite
important for my application because
obviously my list of agents is highly
secret and I don't want it falling into
enemy hands
but really doing this allows me to
demonstrate to you some features that we
just shipped about three weeks ago in
our preview 6 release of blazer we've
now got built in infrastructure for
dealing with authorization and
authentication first principle of
security when you're doing client-side
development is your security is not on
the client okay all real access control
has to happen on the server because
anything you do on the client can be
bypassed by anybody with just a basic
awareness of browser dev tools so the
first thing we want to do is secure the
access to our agents list in server-side
code and you can do that really easily
you've probably done this before if
you've done any asp net core so i'm
going to go to my agents controller this
is the server-side endpoint that returns
the data you can see it's just hard
coded but it could actually go to a
database and I'm going to use a feature
that's been in there for years and years
probably longer than some of you've even
been alive called authorize and that's
just an
attribute that tells the server you can
only get to this data if you are
authorized and what does it mean to be
authorized well it depends how you've
configured it and in this case I've
configured it here to say when it comes
to authentication I want to use JSON web
tokens who's used JSON web tokens in a
application for like more than half you
for the rest of you a JSON web token is
just a string it's a string that says
who you are and what roles you're in and
what anything else the server wants to
say about you and that string is then
signed by the server so the server knows
that no one can tamper with it or make
up their own claims about who they are
the server gives that string to the
client and then when the client wants to
make a request later it includes the
string in the request so the server can
look it in say oh yeah that's a valid
signed string I can pause that and see
who you are and then I can trust you
okay so now I've enforced that in the
server
I'll recompile my application and
hopefully now since I'm not logged in I
should not be able to get that list of
agents anymore so if I go to this list
of agents you'll see that it just stays
stuck in this loading state forever and
in fact if we look in the browser dev
tools you'll see the server replied 401
unauthorized which makes sense because
we didn't send any JSON web token with
that request
okay so we'll deal with logging in a
second but first let's think about the
user experience for logged out users
currently the experience is this it just
gets stuck in loading now that's not a
very cool experience it would be better
if it tells you that you can't see it
cuz you're not authorized and you have
to log in wouldn't it be nice if we
could do that in a really simple way for
example if we could take the authorize
attribute that we know and love from
server-side programming and also use it
in the client as well well that's a
feature that we've just added a few
weeks ago I can now say I want to add an
attribute to agents component authorize
so now you'll only be able to see that
if you're authorized as far as the
client is concerned and I'll talk about
what that means in a minute ok so now
when I go over onto this page instead of
getting the loading screen
I'll just get access denied only logged
in mission commanders may access this
area now believe it or not that's not
the default message that's
that's something I've customized so it's
really easy to customize how that looks
and you can put custom content in there
okay so we've got a better logged out
experience now but I want to deal with
actual logging again in fact I want to
show whether you're logged in or not
up here in the top right of my page and
so where does that text come from today
well it's coming from login displayed
razor which is a little component it's a
very simple component as you can see
it's just a bit of static text so what I
want to do is display different content
depending on whether the user is logged
in or not and I can do that using
another one of our newly shipped
features which is the built-in
authorized view component an authorized
view gives you a context variable from
which you can get information like the
user's login name so you can say hello
however you are and if the users not
logged in at all they won't see anything
but I want to do slightly more than that
I want to display a whole different set
of UI depending on whether you're logged
in or not so I'm going to dump in this
big chunk of code and you can see what
it does is if you are authorized will
display this icon and will say hello
your name and then we'll have them one
of my material design buttons and it
will say when you click it we're going
to log you out because it you know if
you're logged in you probably want to be
able to log out and if you're not
authorized will display a button that
just says login and what does it mean to
login well we're going to call a method
on login dialog login dialog is a thing
that I've added in my project here and
I'm using the ref' keyword to get a
reference to it so I can call public
methods on it so you click that button
it's going to tell the login dialog to
login okay what's login dialog well when
you first see it it might seem a little
overwhelming but don't be scared it's
not insane it's what is it it's 50 lines
of code which vs currently believes is
invalid but I don't believe it's invalid
so I don't know what VSS is talking
about we'll ignore it for a minute I'm
sure it will wake up in a second there
we go it's happy now right so what have
we got in login dialog well firstly I'm
using a material design dialog and I've
got a couple of text fields that you can
enter a username and a password and as
for where that data goes well I've
defined a class called
login credentials and I've got
of these so if we look at that login
credentials you'll see it's pretty
simple it's just got a username and
password and kind of bizarrely and
except terms but you'll see why I've
added that in a few minutes okay so
we've got an editor for credentials you
can edit user name and password and
there's a checkbox that lets you accept
the terms and then we've got a couple of
buttons one of them is the login button
and when you click it will call submit
credentials and what does that do
well it takes the credentials that the
user has entered and it posts them to
this endpoint on the server and the
server is going to reply with a login
result which may include a JSON web
token if it likes your password and so
if the token is null will say your login
failed but if it's not null then we'll
store that token in our authentication
state provider which is another one of
the things we've recently shipped and
that keeps track of whether the user is
logged in or not and who they're logged
in as then finally we can just make the
dialog go away all right so if this all
works now then when I come back here
I've got my login button I can click on
login and my pretty dialog appears and I
can type in some credentials if I enter
bad credentials the server will say no
and we'll get the message but if we
enter good credentials and I'm not
actually going to accept the terms we'll
deal with that in a minute when I click
login the serve will say yep here's a
JSON web token for you the client can
pause that and get your username out and
then the UI changes to show me the
agents screen but it's still not
displaying the list of agents why is
that
well the server still says 401 or alpha
unauthorized why does the server not
like me even after I've logged in well
the answer is because even though I've
got this token on the client I'm still
not sending it back to the server with
the request so that's the last thing I
need to do I'm going to get this token
by injecting my token authentication
state provider and then from that I can
construct an authentication header
we'll get the token and then we'll build
an HTTP header that's got the name
bearer and the value well it's got the a
value that comes from combining bearer
and token and I'm going to send that on
my request to the server so now
hopefully it should be happy to return
their agents data to me so if I reload
now then because I'm logged in it
actually give me the data and the other
cool think about these built-in
components is they're all designed for
you know interactive client-side use so
they update immediately if I click on
the logout button it will instantly
switch the rest of my application into
the log type merge and if I click in
login again and I enter my password
again then it will immediately switch me
back to the log in state and of course
you can go further and have users in
different roles and policies and all
that kind of stuff but that's the core
set of authentication features all right
let's move on and we'll see some other
new stuff that we recently shipped and
I'm going to show you now validation
that's obviously a very important
feature for many kinds of realistic
applications and we don't have any of it
in this one right now so right now if I
click on if I bring up this login form I
can submit the form even if it's
completely blank and even if I haven't
accepted the terms now the server won't
accept my login so obviously it's not a
good password but I don't think this is
very good
I think we shouldn't even be allowed to
submit the form to the server
unless it's valid so let's add some
validation rules and validation is a
little bit like authorization in the
sense that you often need to do it on
this well in most cases you will want to
enforce your validation rules on the
server and not just on the client if
those validation rules really matter to
you in terms of what data gets stored
you can't trust the client to honor any
client-side validation rules so you do
need to do server-side validation and
that is very straightforward if you're
using a spinet core on the server and
has been for many years so one simple
way you can do it is you can use these
kinds of data annotations attributes so
now on my login credentials I'm saying
that things are required I've got some
length constraints and I'm defining some
error messages okay now that is
technically all I have to do to make my
server start enforcing those rules
because I'm using an API controller on
the server by default it will honor data
for annotations rules so let's see if
that works now if I try to submit a
blank form that's not what I expected to
happen
did I not do that
I try building this all again I'm gonna
submit a blank form and okay that is
what I expected happen so now I appear
to get no response at all from the
server so why did the server not respond
well actually it did respond it
responded 400 bad request and actually
gave a list of the reasons why it was a
bad request and what the validation
errors were but I'm not really
interested in that what I am interested
in is now also enforcing the same
validation rules with client-side
validation and hopefully I don't have to
define my rules in more than one place
because they're all shared on a single
class that share between the server and
the client so how do we do client-side
validation with Blaser well we can use
some relatively new things that came out
I think in preview 5 and the first thing
I'm going to use is something called an
edit form okay an edit form is something
you can wrap around part of your UI and
what it does is it keeps track of an
edit operation that is in progress so it
knows what fields are being edited
whether they've been modified and what
validation message is applied to them at
any given time and if you wanted to do
validation then you need to tell it what
object it is that we're going to be
validating when the form is submitted
and you also have to tell it how to
validate that object and in this case
because I'm using data annotations rules
I'm going to add a data annotations
validator into my form there and that's
more or less all you have to do but I
want to do a little bit more firstly if
there are errors I think it would be
polite to actually display them on the
screen in some way so I'm going to add a
validation summary down here at the
bottom of my form and finally if the
form is invalid I don't want you to be
able to submit it the server anymore so
I'm going to change this button so it
doesn't invoke the server directly but
instead what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say for the form itself if
there's a valid submission as far as
client-side validation is concerned then
we're willing to submit it to the server
right let's see if this actually does
the validation now so I'm going to click
login and I'll try to submit a blank
form and what happens is it does in fact
run the validation on the client there
so we know which fields are required
we know that the terms must be accepted
that's a good start but I think it's a
little ugly right now I don't like
having this list down here I'd like to
have different messages in different
places so what I'm going to do is get
rid of the validation summary and
instead I'm going to use another
built-in thing called validation message
and so we say what it is that we want to
validate I want the user names message
to appear up there and then below that
I'll display any message for password
and below that I'll display any message
that we've got for accept terms let's
see if that looks a little bit better
now so now if I submit a blank form
you'll see I get different messages in
different places you'll see that the
fields can get highlighted that's just
control through CSS and as I start
typing stuff in you'll see that they get
marked as valid and the messages
disappear and as I toggle this box
obviously the message for that will
appear or disappear and if finally it's
valid I'll be allowed to login okay so
it's called it's quite so validation and
it's designed to interoperate very
easily with what you're doing on the
server okay now last set of things that
I'm going to show you inside the mission
controller application is component
libraries and static content the ability
to have static content in external
projects and packages is a new feature
that we just shipped in preview six and
it makes it easier to build libraries of
components so why am I talking about
this well so far I've been using that
material design component library which
is all very well but someone's got to
create these libraries in the first
place so how could we create our own
component library and make it reusable
well what I want to do is I kind of like
my site at the moment but I'm not really
a big fan of lists I think it would be
way cooler if instead of a list we were
to display an interactive 3d map showing
where all the agents were around the
city but you know interactive 3d maps
will probably take quite a while to
implement so what I want to do is use an
existing JavaScript one that I can find
and turn that into a blazer component
library so that that 3d map can be used
in any blazer application very easily
right now you'll see in my solution here
I've got a project already
that I've created Corp in map library
and it doesn't really have anything in
it yet apart from a dub-dub-dub root
folder and inside there I've got a
javascript file called pin map j/s so
that's the library that I want to use
it's actually a wrapper again around yet
another library but I want to make this
available to anyone who consumes this
project or package so how can I do that
do I need to create some custom build
steps to copy this javascript file into
your project or something no I don't
actually have to do anything anymore
because of this new feature if you have
a class library that uses the razor SDK
then by default anything from the
dub-dub-dub root folder will become
available to the thing that consumes it
so to consume one of these bits of
static content you just need to know
about the URL conventions so here to
consume that pin map library you can see
that I've got a script tag that uses
this special format underscore content
and then the name of the project or
package that contains the content and
then the path within that content to the
thing that I want to use so that's all
it takes for the person who uses your
library to use the static content from
inside it okay so that's a good start
but I want to make an actual blazer
component here for this map so I'm gonna
make a new item and I'll choose Razor
component and I will call it pin map
razor and what should we put inside pin
map tracer well it would be nice if yeah
we go great so I would like to put a
little bit of HTML inside there to get
started with so here
it's pretty simple I've just got a div
and the first thing I want to do is
check that when I use this map it
actually shows up in the UI so I'm gonna
go back to my agents page and I'm gonna
say I don't want to have this HTML table
anymore I'm gonna delete that completely
and instead I want to use this pin map
so I'm gonna type pin map and you'll see
I get immediately prompted to use this
library this component for my library
and the first thing to notice is that
Blazer components are for actual dotnet
classes so they've got as well as a
class name they've got a namespace
you can reference them through their
fully qualified name if you want to but
if you don't want to then what you can
do is add a using statement so I can say
using pin map library and then when I
try to add the tag down here you'll see
and now get prompted not just with the
fully qualified name but also with the
shortened name because of my using
statement there alright so let's see if
this does actually show up in the UI
when I reload it now says to do render
map good and we've still got that agents
text which I want to get rid of so let's
lose that and then I'll go back to my
pin map and I want to actually interact
with the JavaScript library now so we're
going to do a little bit of JavaScript
Interop to turn this div into an actual
map so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to start by injecting a service that
lets me make JavaScript Interop calls
the JavaScript runtime and then using
that I can make a call I'm going to say
when this component gets rendered I want
to make a call to JavaScript to a
function in JavaScript called pin map
create or update and that function needs
me to pass an actual element instance to
it so that it knows where to put the map
so I need to pass this div into the
JavaScript how can I get a reference to
this div in some way well I can do sir
using the ref directive attribute I can
say ref for this equals map LM that's
just giving a name to it and then I'll
define a field where that stuff can go
there we go and now this is all valid
code so we can refer to our map LM here
and that will be the element that gets
passed to JavaScript okay so let's see
if this actually makes the pin map
display in my UI I'll come back and I'll
hit reload and we'll see do we get the
actual map and the answer is yes we do
we do get this map box map and we can
see this hold downtown Manhattan area
and we can scroll around and that's all
very cool but I want to not just show an
empty map but rather I want to show
where my agents are on the map and the
way it works with this particular
library is that it wants you to put
these map pin
Elements Insider and that defines where
the pin goes with its longitudinal
attitude and whatever markup you want to
show up when you click on that pin but I
don't want to just display a single map
pin I want to display lots of map pins
one for each of my agents so I'm going
to say this component takes a parameter
which is an enumerable of agents and
using that enumerable I can do a for
each loop to display a map pin for each
of them so I'm going to loop over all
the data and for each one I'll use their
longitude and latitude and I'll display
their name and their mission inside the
caption okay last thing to do is I need
to actually pass this data property here
into my pin map so I need to make Visual
Studio wake up let's try that again data
and then I can pass the agents into it
and hopefully that will render all of
the elements for the pins let's try it
I'll reload again and now hopefully
we'll see lots of little red spots
corresponding to each of my agents so I
can see for example here on Broadway
I've got Tim who's I can't remember why
I asked him to get a part in a Broadway
show but I'm sure there's an important
reason for that and then we can have a
look down here maybe at this pier and we
can see we've got someone intercepting
enemy shipments and yeah so I'm pretty
happy as a spymaster that all my agents
are doing useful stuff across the city
now but the more important point is that
we can make these components put them
into libraries and make them easy to
consume and reuse okay right then let's
move on to look at the broader world now
because I've only shown you one of many
possible ways of using Blaser there's
much much more to this so far all I've
shown you is that we can take Blaser and
run it on web assembly inside your
browser and have it interact with the
Dom directly inside the browser that's
what we call client-side Blaser but this
architecture is really flexible and the
fact that we've got this separation
between how your components render and
how they tell the Dom to update means
that we can run it in different ways for
example we can
you're the Blazer part of your
application for.net part and if you
wanted you can run that in the cloud and
a server that's running somewhere
remotely and then when it wants to
update someone's UI it can do that by
pushing updates over a WebSocket signal
our connection so that the browser knows
how to update and that's what we call
server-side blazer and that is going to
be shipping with asp net core later asp
net core 3 later this year
so let me give you a little demo of that
and then we'll talk about how the pros
and cons line up so I'm not going to do
it with the agents thing anymore I'm
going to show you a slightly different
application now this one's called car
buyer and I'll show you how it looks and
then we'll talk about some of the
implementation details and what it's
doing behind the scenes so what this is
it's the sort of thing that you could
use to buy a car believe it or not you
could maybe use it at home on your own
but more likely you go into a car
showroom and some person comes out with
an iPad and they tap all the buttons and
they persuade you to spend a lot more
money than you were going to spend
before so it works like this you go okay
I probably like to look at this eight
system here
what engine shall I put on I probably
put the most powerful engine on I'll go
next from there what color I like the
look of red I'll put the massive I'll
eyes on it and yeah everyone loves Sun
roofs and self-parking that sounds
really fancy definitely wants some of
that and then you think ok we'll go on
from there next how am I going to pay
for this oh well that's very expensive
so I think I'm probably gonna need a
loan so hmm $4,000 a month and we better
change that repayment period maybe a bit
more maybe a bit more still ok it's
still pretty expensive but maybe we can
tolerate this now and then finally we're
going to move on and we get their
delivery details and stuff so what's the
point of showing that well the point
really is to look at how this is working
behind the scenes and what's going on so
the code for our application here is
this project here car bio dot
server-side and this is a regular
server-side asp net core application
which is hosting my server-side blazer
but I haven't actually got any
components in here
for some bizarre reason that you'll
understand in a few minutes I've decided
to factor out all my components into
this other library called carbide core
which is just a class library that
contains a bunch of components for
things like choosing delivery and
choosing options and stuff like that so
normally you wouldn't do that it would
be strange to factor stuff out into a
project but it just goes to show that
you can if you want to and also I have a
good reason that you'll see in a few
minutes as for how this is working
inside the browser this is a very
lightweight way of running your blazer
application we don't have to download
mono web assembly anymore we don't have
to fetch any of your net assemblies if
we look at the network tab you'll see
that what we do fetch is now just a
small number of things and it's kind of
difficult on this screen but we'll zoom
in and you'll see that we're fetching
just the HTML CSS some images and that's
it apart from one more thing which is
we're opening this signal our connection
to this end point on the server called
underscore blazer and that's where all
the interactivity is happening so when
the page starts up it opens this
connection and says I'm ready and when
the user performs any actions we send a
message to the server to tell them what
they've done and the server replies to
describe how the UI should be updated if
you want to see that you can look at the
actual binary messages that are getting
sent so if I clear that out and then I
make some change like I click on next
you'll see that various binary messages
get sent these messages are for things
like there was a click event on a
particular element within the render
tree and the server gets that and it
says ok I'll re render the application
I'll compute the death against its
previous state and I'll send a minimal
description of what UI updates are
needed to bring the UI up to date and
each of those messages is generally
pretty small it's usually measured in
the tens or hundreds of bytes because
this is a very efficient compact
transport format and that is how every
time I do anything here the browser is
giving being given instructions to
update now another cool thing about
rendering your application on the server
about running your application on the
server is that we can very easily enable
server-side pre-rendering and what that
means is when the user first goes to
your page
they don't have to wait for the
WebSocket connection to be established
before we can build the initial Europe
UI
what we can do is have the server do the
initial render on the server and send
the initial HTML just as you know
traditional plain old HTML that the
browser can render without even running
any script so to prove that's happening
if I display the page source you'll see
it's not just a script tag it's actually
all the HTML for the initial UI there
and that means your application is easy
to be crawled by search engines which is
great for search engine optimization
now pre-rendering can be done with
client-side laser applications as well
but it's much easier if your server if
your application is already running on
the server anyway okay so that is
server-side Blaser and mainly I've just
given you a list of pros for that I've
told you it's more lightweight which is
great but what are the real full set of
pros and cons to this thing well on the
plus side yes it's like a thin client
situation this is going to run really
fast even on very low-end devices
because they don't really have to
download anything significant at all
they just basically put displaying a
remote view of your application so it's
very lightweight also because your code
runs on the server now it's not running
on webassembly it's running on full net
core on the server and you have access
to literally anything that dotnet core
can do when it's running on a server
which is a lot of stuff and then finally
you may be able to make your
architecture simpler this way so what do
I mean by that I mean normally when
you're doing data access for a
client-side application you have to do
it by making HTTP requests to some
endpoint on the server which then
queries the database on your behalf see
realises it all is JSON and sends that
back but with server-side laser you
don't even need to do most of that your
code is already running on the server
there's no need to have special API
endpoints if you want to talk to a
database you can just talk to a database
like directly you can go through a
repository pattern if you want to but
there's no need just be serializing
stuff and making API endpoints so it
just simplifies your architecture
significantly however there's the cons
as well there are some real drawbacks to
this model so you have to balance this
and decide what's best for you the first
con is because this is running truly on
the
there's no way you're making this thing
run offline every interaction is
happening on the server
another thing is latency and this is a
basic problem with physics the basic
problem is that unfortunately the speed
of light is really really slow and it's
sold so distressing that light is so
slow and that we can't do anything about
it the basic reality of it is that if
your server is a hundred milliseconds
away in speed of light time then you've
got at least a 200 millisecond
round-trip so there will be latency
basic physics finally in terms of the
fact that this code is running on the
server means you're now paying for that
CPU time whereas with the client-side
model each user brings their own CPU to
execute your code so it's up to you to
decide which of those is the right fit
for you but that's not the full range of
options there are in fact more options
still for it for a blazer application so
let's think about the ways that
applications can be deployed today you
can imagine there's a spectrum with it a
one extreme end there's the web with
HTML and CSS and JavaScript and it runs
in your browsers and at the other end
there's native applications that run on
people's desktops for all the different
operating systems which parts of that
spectrum can we target with Blaser well
I've just shown you server-side laser
there and that's at the extreme end of
server side of web there because every
single thing is happening on the server
and we are even sending the initial HTML
as being pre-rendered so that's a very
web-centric way of doing development but
with Blaser you've got more options so
you've already seen that we can run
Blaser client-side and in fact we can
make our application on the client even
work offline so let me show you i've got
car buyer here that runs on the server
but i've also got another one car by our
client side which i'll set as my start
up project and again I don't have any
components in there because I'm actually
using the exact same set of components
from car buyer core just to show you
that we can run the same code in two
different environments without having to
change the code so if you know now run
that you'll see we're now running the
same application to the same
interactivity no code changes but it's
now running client-side
and because this is a client-side
application we can even make it work
offline so I've already added the
relevant Service Worker which means that
I can go over here and tell my browser
that I want it to be in offline mode and
normally webpages don't work when you're
offline but because this one has got my
Service Worker when I hit reload what
happens is it just shows up and it works
and it's still fully interactive so
we've now got a dotnet
application running inside a browser
with full support for being offline okay
very good but can we get any further
towards a desktop application well we
can what if instead of running it inside
people's browsers we want it to have its
own application window and be
installable in into the operating system
well that brings us to the idea of a
progressive web application or a PWA and
any web application that can run offline
can be a PWA so I can make my car by
application there installable into the
user's operating system and in fact
that's what I've already done so if I
what am i doing right so if I go to my
Start menu here and I look you'll see
I've got car buyer on my Start menu
right there so if I click it what comes
up the same application but now it's not
apparently inside a browser it's now
inside its own window and it's
installable it's a got its own Start
menu entry etc so that's the whole idea
of PWA and we can target that too very
good but what else could we do is there
some way that we could go even further
with that
well what if we didn't want to run on
web assembly the people told me wait
does run on webassembly because pwace
are purely web technologies what if we
wanted to do the same desktop
installable application but now we want
it to run on dotnet core just regular
native code not under web assembly at
all well that brings us to
electron-electron is a way of running
HTML based application that's
installable and we've set up a way of
connecting it to a regular dotnet core
process now this is not product we're
shipping right now but it is a sample
that we've published that you can try
out yourself so let's have a go at doing
that and if we look in the third folder
here you'll see I
got Kabaya electron and again it has the
same reference to carbide core because
again it's the same components running
without any code changes and if I run
that then what we'll see is an electron
window pops up and again the same
application works same interactivity but
now we've got all the features of
electron for example all the ways that
integrates into the operating system all
the ways that it deals with managing
updates over time and of course now
we're not running on webassembly at all
so that takes is really really far down
this spectrum to being a desktop
application so you probably think that's
pretty cool that's so that's really
flexible that's one programming model
that can operate in a whole range of
different scenarios but do you think
that we could push it any further like
that is there any way that we could push
this like right into the infrared part
of the spectrum here and get even more
desktop like than we already have
well what would that even mean well so
far all of our rendering has been based
on HTML and CSS what if we wanted to
blaze our application that renders using
something not HTML and CSS is that even
possible
well it is and I'm going to show you but
first I'm going to caution you this is
not something that we have any plans
around productizing okay this is purely
a tech demo that I'm showing you that
the architectural blazer is flexible
enough for you to create your own
renderer for blazer that can target
different kinds of rendering
technologies so let's give an example of
how we can have a blazer application
that renders to something that's not
even HTML so I'm going to go to another
project that I've got right here and I
wonder if from the name you can guess
how this is going to work it's called
blutter
and when I run this what's going to come
up is a flutter application so what's
flutter
well flutter is a cross-platform UI
technology flutter applications can run
on Windows or Mac on Linux on Android
and on iOS and by default they have this
kind of Android styling but you can make
them look like iOS or anything else that
you create the renderer for and so what
I've got here is I've got this counter
that counts
your clicks on a button I've got this
to-do list and I can
type stuff and it adds stuff into a list
and then you know I can do all the other
stuff you'd expect for example scrolling
I can mark things as done I can show
this little slide a side bar thing and
so on now a flutter application is
usually built with the dart programming
language but I did not build it with
Dart
can you guess why I built it with yes of
course you can guess I built it with
blazer and dotnet core so how does the
code for my application look well here
is the main layout for my application
and you will notice that it's not HTML
there's no HTML in here I cannot use
HTML even if I wanted to because there's
no browser what I can use instead are
all these different flutter widgets so
I've got a scaffold that's the overall
layout for the application I've got an
app bar with a title I've got a draw
that appears on the side I've got a tab
bar and some tab bar views and I've also
got some custom components of my own for
example counter and if we go over there
you'll see it looks pretty familiar
although we're not using HTML now we've
still got a button and when you press it
it's going to call dotnet code and so
just like we did with the counter in the
web we're able to update this count and
display that in the middle of our UI and
similarly we could go and have a look at
this to-do list here and it might seem a
little bit like what on earth is all
this stuff well this is how flutter
deals with styling we've got things like
column and row and flexible and things
like that and inside there to display
that list you'll see I'm able to just
use normal C sharp for each loop because
it's the normal blazer programming model
here and I can display my to-do list my
to-do entry and inside the to-do entry
well that's just got a check box and
text and of course I can update the code
for my application if I wanted for
example let's say whenever you check on
these boxes I want to draw a line
through the text to show that it's done
so I can use the line through feature of
text in flutter to say I want to display
a line through if the item is done if
it's done ok good and then I'll quit
click restart for my application and now
when I add stuff
then when I click on this button you'll
see the line through appears and when I
unclick it it goes away and this is a
proper net core application I can even
use things like the debugger in Visual
Studio so if I set a breakpoint right
there and pop up my application one more
time then when I click on this count
button you'll see we of course hit the
breakpoint and we can inspect the stay
of the application and so on so the
point of me showing you all this stuff
is just to say that this is a really
flexible architecture and following the
same programming model we can enable you
to target an enormous range of different
kinds of applications and you can pick
whatever you think is the best point on
the spectrum for whatever kind of
application you're building and in a lot
of cases you can reuse your code in your
components across different UI
technologies so that is all I'm going to
have time to show you there is a lot
more that you can go and learn about
Blaser if you want to tons and tons of
features which I don't have time to show
you if you want to learn more about them
then I would recommend that you go to
Blizzard net where you'll find the
instructions for getting started and the
links to their documentation and if you
want the code and the slides from this
talk it's already published you can go
to that short URL there which will take
you to a repo on github and you can get
access to that stuff so that's all we've
got time for I hope that's been useful
to you I hope you remember to evaluate
the session on your way out and I hope
that you really enjoy the rest of the
conference
[Applause]